from 22 to 30 every human on earth
should live with four roommates in a
[__] hole and go for every dream they
have as hard as humanly possible now if
you're going to be that kid and you're
going to go for your dream pay attention
to this next part attention is the
number one asset but I know that you
guys some of you will have questions for
Gary um oh hey brother what's your name
my name is a um so you've run so many
successful businesses is um a lot of
them have been the single business that
you've run have been successful enough
to Val you for your whole life yes what
gives you the ambition to jump from
business to business when you know that
one of the businesses is enough for you
to keep going forever what gives you
that courage to go from one business to
another business in completely different
fields because I view my business life
as playing games I don't to your point
if I viewed my life from the framework
of it being the financial needs I needed
to live my life and my lifestyle I'd be
done
already I just don't W I don't want to
do that I don't want to
ski like I don't want to golf all day I
don't want to go to San trpe and be on a
yacht and drink Rosé I I I don't like
that except for maybe three days a year
I want to build businesses it's the game
it's the challenge I
professionally navigate my day-to-day
the way every person right now if they
closed their eyes and thought about what
they like to do the most for a day
whether it's ski golf yacht cook listen
to music watch movies make music like it
is my favorite thing to do it's why I
got such poor grades I was incapable to
even get C's cuz I couldn't give up
every second of my 9 10 11 12 13 14 year
old self to not try to sell trading
cards in the back of the classroom or
daydream about things I would do for my
dad's liquor store couldn't even give
them a minute so it's it's who I
am okay um I like the story about your
mom
being a
gangster but also like the fact that
you're investig in people and you so
many things going in my head right now
how do you be how do you become gutless
in business and once you've got your
funding from an investor how do you not
get ambushed like how do you how do you
what mistakes that people do once
they've got their funding and they if
you're talking about once you start a
business that's funded by a VC the
mistake they do is they make every
action to get the next round of funding
I'm talking about like you know M house
as well oh I see do not
convince courage or lack of
fear with
Insanity do not right like to to me I
have never done anything professionally
the first 12 years of my career my Dad
paid me somewhere between $4 and $80,000
a year I made very little money in the
scheme of things to 34 years old during
that time I almost bought
nothing I lived in a very uncomfortably
humbly apartment I saved money making
$50,000 a year when you think about
things like losing your house like when
I say sell your home and then go live in
an apartment so that you can buy
yourself two years of coverage to go
start something that's about regret
that's different than having some random
idea and maxing your credit cards out
like there's
frivolous and then there's strategic for
your happy happiness and so it's very
nuanced and has to be important this is
also why I tell everybody in their 20s
if you're 20 to 30 you should be doing
nothing but high-risk Behavior this is
how the world has everything backed up
backwards we tell kids that at 22 it's
time to get
serious and they should have everything
figured out and you must go get a
practical job they're going to live to
100 that is insane from 22 to 30 every
on Earth should live with four
roommates in a [__] hole sorry sorry I
let you buy $1 bad
food and go for every dream they have as
hard as humanly possible now if you're
going to be that kid and you're going to
go for your dream pay attention to this
next part and you're not allowed to ask
your parents for money your parents
should not be the funer of your dream
you should because if your parents are
you will become an entitled
loser but if you do it you will actually
have the behaviors that may lead you to
accomplish it but if you don't you will
feel so good at 28 2930 when you decide
to go do something practical that you
actually tried a lot of us in this room
over 3540 didn't get this chance cuz the
internet wasn't this internet but the
world we live in now the most practical
thing every 22 to 30 year old should do
is to go for it but that's different
than like hey I have a three-year-old
child I've got this idea it's going to
be the next Facebook and you Mor you
know you mortgage everything on this
wild dream there's too much delusion
that's very different than strategic
practical happiness reset so just want
to make sure we have that calibrated
we've got time for one more question hi
Gary how are you first I want to say a
massive thank you because you've really
inspired my entrepreneurial Journey
thank you brother for a huge reason I
started my company um so I started a
company we sell flavor two fix yes uh so
my first question is if you think flavor
two fix is a good business
idea my second question why why did you
start it um basically we've seen like
chewing G is a huge market and for 100
years has been no real Alternatives yes
and TR Gard like it's got plastic inside
yeah of course it's great toothpicks
think toothpicks are much cooler much
more badass do you know how big the
toothpick Market is globally do you have
any sense I'm C I'm genuinely curious no
I I mean it's kind of like we have to
create the market for ourselves yes I
well from a flavored standpoint but the
overall but but you know so let me tell
you why I do like it yeah I believe that
the world that the past will tell you
the future so ironically I asked you
those questions cuz I was curious about
how you were thinking about it but
ironically you're going to be very
excited to hear this I've actually
looked looked at starting a toothpick
business I we should work
together you willing to give up 99% of
your
Equity um you know I looked at it about
six or seven years ago
because you know there have been pockets
in the last 100 years where toothpick
culture was very high and I actually
think that there is room for it to get
cool again 100% I think it's j could I
get you to try one real quick you sure
[Applause]
can M
mint how are you I'm very good I'm folk
lovely to meet you pleasure thank you so
much for doing this what flavors what
flavors you good so we have Macho mint
pleasing Peach mindful match up and we
just released two new flavors mango
Madness and Cosmic Cola how much is this
uh so we're currently selling them in
triple packs so we sell three packs for1
what that means you're making real
profit
stop for that part in the video so why
are you selling them why are you selling
them uh so we sell them online on a
website so we uh have you have you had
any viral Tik Tok creative yet
yes uh so so we we actually we launched
back in April and um we were're we at
around um 490k followers so what's the
name of the company uh it's called pick
pick them yeah look it up look it up um
yes we kind of using like Tik Tok as a
real driving force and uh so this is
real feedback yes so as someone who
ironically genuinely does use toothpicks
a lot often the the first thing that so
first of off from a flavor standpoint
very good yeah like I I like it like
it's flavor from a flavor standpoint I'm
happy I like I like where you're focused
on social that's real that goes back to
the Practical you could do it at night
and you could do things like many more
people here can achieve things than they
realize because of where social is I
think from a product standpoint I'm
surprised how quickly it's breaking on
me cuz I chew you know like do you know
that already yeah I mean we we we're
constantly yeah of course of course that
would be my first like like quick
observation that for the small group of
people like myself who actually use
toothpicks guys it's breaking too fast
but the reality is most people if it got
hot wouldn't know it cuz they wouldn't
have context but I do think that that's
something to get them through them
faster and then B more yeah exactly fair
enough to be fair I do feel
gangster I think it suits you I think it
suits you too I think you could should
continue the I I actually genuinely
think that this could become a thing the
way fashion Works fashion circles this
was very big in the 50s and 60s I think
a lot of people do want to get out of
bad habits one of the things I'm
incredibly concerned about is how
accepted Vape culture is for kids like I
don't know what we're all doing about
this it's a joke like we put all that
work in to get them off cigarettes and
now they're on this [__] and I have a
very good feeling that in 20 years
everyone's like oh no everyone's dying
from cancer from this like this is black
and white to me so like I get excited
about something like this not only from
the entrepreneurial journey and I hope
this works for you but this is the kind
of thing that I think could also get
people that want to get off bad behavior
no a lot of people have said that it's
stopped them vaping so it's been
good for you cheers let clap it
[Applause]
up where are you [__] making these
things got a question for you I have a
question please hi um so i r a past BR
Asian City mainly because you inspired
me to start building with past brand in
2018 so thank you very much of course um
I think the biggest issue with an agency
as you've probably found much more
acutely than I have is scaling human
capital right yes selling people as a
product yes how do you effectively scale
that keep good people without I anyway
but obvious how do you scale that human
capital in a way that's sustainable to a
point like the level that you are
because the biggest isue I've had is we
get great people in they develop through
their career or startup they read
ceiling we can't put more they move on
or we bring people in and their [__] the
thing that worked for us is we grew so
fast that we didn't have
ceilings at the same Pace that most
do and then the other thing I did I
don't need to rekindle it was I really
went deep on the people we're a
14-year-old company with 100 employees
that have been there for over 10 years
that's insane especially in adland you
know right so the two things you need to
focus on is spending so much time with
the the second how many people do you
have two of my team that we 10 now 11
yeah oh you should have them all move in
with you like basically do I would say
this I would say and this is like
obviously with them there but this is
like real talk you have to go into your
head and decide which of the 10 to 11
hopefully for you all 10 or 11
realistically the way the world actually
works four or five whoever the four to
five you think are that you want to be
with you in 6 years from today you must
completely change your behavior with
them tonight you must genuinely actually
no [__] treat them like family ask
them the questions that are scary for
small companies you know I've been
through it which is like what drives you
cuz when they're like money and you
don't have it you're like uh oh like you
know but you have to have those comos
and on the other side you must at all
costs focus on Business Development to
get more business in because that those
dollars are feeding the oxygen for the
retention because inevitably for so many
of them money is going to be one of the
variables right but inevitably out of 10
of them five of them are going to
believe in you longterm so much that
they'll be able to invest too just like
so many of the people that work for me
that are 10 years and longer they made
very little money we were a smaller
company but they believed so much in me
and then they got rewarded on the other
side of the rainbow and I'm proud of
that and that builds that r and you're
going to have to have those
conversations yeah I mean I want to say
the power of personal branding and kudos
to you were 100% inbound
because I'm proud of you it's funny the
uh the book that is coming next next
year or this year we're here now uh I'm
putting out day trading
attention it was originally called jab
jab jab left hook it's the update to
that book because I got so much feedback
like you're giving me now about that
book that I decided to write the 2024
version I'm really excited about it and
like as you know even in this short
window how to be great at social media
content not only changes every year it
changes every month it changes every
week and so thank you for saying that
and I'm excited about the new book Thank
You Gary yes I'm very proud of you for
you only th swore three
times Gary thank you so much you have
been absolutely incredible I think
everyone will agree yeah thank you uh we
appreciate you being here thank you so
much right Gary I'm going to be very
Unapologetic and take somebody's time
apologies no worries um 2019 Wednesday
the 20th do you know what you was doing
I do not you was in Birmingham and you
spoke and I was there and you told me to
jump on Tik Tok I uploaded that day and
now it's my full-time job so I just want
to say thank you appreciate you and now
I want to say can I get you on a piece
of content 100% okay cool um so how's
your general knowledge My overall
general knowledge solid I'm very deep in
stuff I would say I'm solid in general
knowledge Okay cool so I've got two
questions for you um how well firstly
how's your geography geography yeah
solid right we're in the UK so how many
countries are there in the UK um four
four can you name them Scotland Wales
England
is Island all right you got help the all
right last one last four right yeah yeah
last one last one last one just repeat
after me red red blue blue yellow yellow
what color is the grass
green I've already got G I've already
tricked him no no no no you got it wrong
I believe you yeah no you got it wrong
no repeat after me red red blue blue
yellow yellow what color is the grass
what color is the grass there we go
there we go thank you Gary cheers I
appreciate you stay it's really
refreshing hear you not swear thank you
I appreciate that thank you thank you
for saying that they could take a
picture of course be two two
one thank you ladies cheers thank you so
much of course take care of
yourself thanks so much you're welcome
cheers really like what you were saying
about kids and losing I have to
they have to lose we've completely
missed this one it's we're teaching them
that losing is bad then they become
scared of it and then they can't it's
it's just it's so like I'm so empathetic
to why we got there it was well intended
but it is destroyed them and I don't use
that word lightly it is destroyed so
many people in their late teens and
early 20s in the world are just not in a
great place cuz they think making a
mistake or losing or failure is like
death and life is hard you got to get
used true I used to get the slipper yeah
of course I mean of course and I lived
in a beach when I was 20 so you know yes
I know um I didn't know who you were
before but I'm really um inspired so
thank you it's nice to meet
you you too thank you what do you look
for can I just ask you one question you
said about entrepreneurs what when
you're an age or what do you look for in
them you know I I just take the meeting
you know and I listen to their logic and
I ask them question because I am one
it's not very complicated for me to
understand it it's like all of us
whatever you really are it's not hard
for you to know your own and so because
I'm such an entrepreneur if I spend 45
minutes and listen to you say this is my
business I'm going to have a good sense
yeah I used to take spend too much time
paying attention to the idea now I'm
spending more time with your ability
it's kind of like the jockey and the
horse I us to spend too much time on a
horse I need to know if you know how to
ride the
horse how are you I'm good how are you
good do you want to ask a quick question
please so I run a small business
community so helping more people come
together feel less lonely and less
isolated but I'm finding that a lot of
people say they want to feel more
connected and don't actually do the
connection and they don't take the
opportunities any advice to get them
more engaged um
so in that scenario I would go to the
people that directly one-onone that
didn't show up and actually have a 20
minute conversation with them on why and
then take the feedback of 30 or 40
people and see if you can find the
Insight I believe it's because most
people are either one of two things one
they say it but they don't mean it yeah
like the world is filled with that two
they feel like they don't have time for
it because are so daytoday in their
small business they want to come and
network but they think if they're out of
their business for an hour that it's a
problem so they're either stuck
micromanaging or they don't actually
have the energy the spirit or the intent
by telling you that they want to they
feel they accomplished
it you know like writing something on a
vision board means nothing unless you do
something about it absolutely the world
has gotten very comfortable that by
saying something or typing something
that they've actually accomplished
something when that is very not true so
they'll tell you yeah yeah yeah you know
and then they feel like they did it
without actually doing it so it's one of
those two that's really help have a good
picture oh man I appreciate you so much
thank you in 100 in 2014 learned what
you said repeated in an accent people
paid me and now I am where I am that's
amazing do you remember John cwell the
I set that up remember go with you in
the end Dr
day you know what they're like they
don't get content I understand let me
yeah let me do this thank
you thanks appreciate it thank you sorry
no worries at
all cheers man good to see you cheers
keep it up stay
well do both of us for one we both work
in that West in the marketing team so we
were like we always loved your content
thank you so much just wanted to like
and it's so funny when you talk about
like people who want to get out of their
job go you know I work at a
bank yeah but it's like how do you like
differentiate the vision from like like
strategy from the frivolous and
determine what is the best path for
yourself and what you should do yeah
it's like hard to know it's like there's
so many things you can do out there
right it's like yeah I think it's a
great question I think too many people
chase the thing that they'll make the
most that they think will make the most
money yeah and I always say chase the
thing that you like the most because
then you'll work on it the most cuz you
like it which in the end actually gets
you to the money yeah so that's the
mistake people make they're trying to
find the right Trend or the right idea
meanwhile they go thrifting every
weekend and they could make a million
dollars a year of thrifting and flipping
on the internet so much all the ti
hustles these days there's so many out
there there's so
many thank you you're welcome I wish you
well
just advice um it's Insurance like more
like a boring thing people don't want to
talk about it or want to hear about it
what kind of advice we give put a
message out there if it's a topic that's
more boring yeah like Insurance business
make it more about you make it more
about the education people are bored to
your point about insurance until they
need
insurance and so if you're consistent
then you're there and there all you have
to do is give good information good
information and give stories tell
stories of things that people did well
and not well and you become
valuable so much how are you I'm good
what the first thing that you do is take
a phone yes what's the
second so the to the question you're
really asking the thing that I really do
and it may be the sometimes is even
before I grab the phone it may be before
I brush my teeth but pretty quickly
every morning what actually often after
I grab my phone when I grab my phone and
nothing bad happened to anybody that I
love I really genuinely say to myself
thank God like I have a very I pretty
much on a daily basis have a single
gratitude moment for it being another
day where the things that I most feared
didn't happen you know I love I think I
think we re like it it blows me away how
much energy and time everyone here
spends on what they don't have what they
want what they
need and they don't take the time to be
grateful for what they actually have
there are 845 million people right this
second that don't have access to clean
water but we conditioned not to have
gratitude and most people find it very
hard to have gratitude yeah it's it's
gratitude is absolutely my fuel I'm just
grateful so to to the other to like
where I think you were going with the
question the one that I do might that
might be a little unique not yeah it's
like just having one gratitude moment
like okay just like you know like I got
a lot of headaches and things but like
thank God this you know yeah Che thank
you so much
cheers just get a quick picture yes cuz
I got one from
Mr hey go how's it going right quick
question I built my business based on
two I think big passions of yours
employees and marketing as a recruitment
marketing agency good for you um I'm
really facing like trouble people just
believing in the power of recruitment
marketing and employer branding and to
attract Talent directly like what do you
think that is like I've tried to ask
them like it's strange right it should
work on paper where who are you trying
to sell that to or convince or story
tell too ambitious smmes so founders of
ambitious firms I don't know whether
it's just it's not you you might just be
going to too small of a firm where they
can't get over the financial hurdle sure
you might just want to level up a hair
higher and see talking to co the owners
of the business well there's a big gap
between a big CE like just bigger yeah
yeah I was talking to HR te I think it's
probably right level yeah yeah thanks
man Che cheers thank
you have a goodp happy
holiday thank you so much you got it
brother can ask one question I take exra
time um I know you spoke about
accountability for Our Generation yes um
but you're also big on taking risk when
you're young 100% so I'm in my final
year if un need trying to build a
business along the side and I'm just
curious feel like I don't have a
complete sense of direction right now
cuz stuff out and that's fine that's
fine but I'm just wondering what your
message is to people my age right is it
to to take risk and go well 100% okay
because you could do absolutely nothing
right for the next 8 years yeah and be
so [__] young and have plenty of time
to live a normal life that you have to
take that accountability has nothing to
do with taking risks accountability is
after you took the risks and you failed
not to blame your parents not to blame
me not to blame the world to blame
yourself the learning that comes from
correct got it thank
you oh yeah sorry hey guys we have like
one minute so can we just rush the
photos for got
it sorry I forgot to ask I wanted to ask
you a question um quite straightforward
I think to be authentic self or play the
game well both and why to play your
authentic self is the actual game okay
the game is a shortterm win okay
authentic self is the long-term win it's
a tortoise in the hair I agree that's
great thank you you got
it cheers take care byebye bye everyone
thank you bye
cheers bye bye to see you cheers
[Music]
cheers